Given that is very clear.
So in the report,
we must see,
on,
we talk about the aborigines,
the natives,
it is the native frontettes,
and from the 3rd generation,
we then talk about the children of immigrants,
so what we could call the 2nd generation,
and immigrants,
therefore first generation children,
uh, immigration,
and well in math,
the gap between this group of natives and
children of immigrant origin
is equivalent to 1 school year late.
So this gap is real,
uh,
it is absolutely factual
in this study.
And there is 1 piece of data that completes this,
is that the level of immigrants,
so directly,
eh,
immigrants who arrive directly,
of school children,
in general,
lowers the French average.
But
so their level,
individually,
if I may say so,
is lower.
But in the fall,
it is the fall of Aboriginal children that is the worst,
and this is even more worrying for the school,
because they say,
it's not even 1 delay to catch up,
is that it really falls apart.
Aboriginal people,
in this study,
they lose 23 points.
By saying,
in the study,
when immigrants remain stable,
so those who recently arrived remain stable,
and the children of immigrants fall by 10 points.
And then there we go,
there is 1 striking detail,
in this in this study,
with an identical socioeconomic background,
children of immigrant origin have the same results
than Aboriginal people.
So 1,
what in.
Clear 1,
1 child whose foreign language at home,
both orally and in writing,
needs more work
including
on the issue of reading comprehension
and therefore
understanding the title of a problem
ofs.
For example,
that a child
whose mother tongue is speaking at home
written at home
French is obviously more difficult
for children who arrive directly,
but 2.
How can we explain that the fall is less strong?
Well,
if at midnight it's economic,
immigrant children
or Aboriginal
behave in the same way
have the same results,
then how to justify
that all priority education policies
be focused
on the suburbs where
immigrant populations?
Because there are rural areas
extremely poor in which these
priority education policies do not exist.
So obviously.